JAKE TAPPER: And our world
lead, a vital remaining
clue into the origins of
the coronavirus pandemic.
But we may never learn
the truth about it.
I'm talking about blood
samples, thousands of them,
thousands of them sitting in
a Wuhan hospital in China.
After two years, the Chinese
government is preparing
to test these samples.
But as it stands, the
World Health Organization
and other foreign
experts will not
be allowed to analyze
the data independently,
meaning the Chinese
government is
in charge of
examining the results
and revealing their findings.
And as Nick Paton Walsh
reports, the Chinese government
doesn't exactly have a track
record of transparency.
- Ground zero for the illness
sparking global unease.
- It is likely a brand
new viral pneumonia.
NICK PATON WALSH: It is perhaps
the last publicly known clue
to where coronavirus came from.
But will the world ever learn
the truth of what it says?
Tens of thousands of tiny
blood samples taken in Wuhan
in the last months of 2019
are still stored in a hospital
there.
- The samples from the
blood bank absolutely
will contain vital clues.
- They could potentially
be very revelatory.
- This is the closest
to the world we've
seen of real time samples.
NICK PATON WALSH: The samples
might reveal when and even
where antibodies
against the virus
first appeared in humans
in October or November
two years ago.
China says they had to be
kept for legal reasons for two
years in case of lawsuits
over the blood transfusions
they are from.
But now, that limit is
almost up for the key months
at the end of 2019.
And a Chinese official
confirmed to CNN
that China is
preparing to test them,
echoing a promise from
July when they said
they would share the results.
- [non-english speech]
NICK PATON WALSH:
Related institutions
from the Chinese
side, he says, also
express that once
they have the results,
they will deliver them to both
the Chinese and foreign expert
teams.
The samples come from
the disposable tubes that
carried donor blood
into the donor bag
and are something the WHO
team said earlier this year
they wanted to examine.
- Team for the origins
of the coronavirus.
NICK PATON WALSH:
They could contain
vital detailed information.
- Might also help us to follow
the trajectory of the spread
of the virus by
tracking the individuals
who may carry the virus.
- And you would like to go
back to find out exactly
during which month
this virus started
to leave fingerprints in the
human population in China.
- It is common practice to
de-identify the samples.
So you could strip it down
to basic demographics, age,
gender, neighborhood,
where they lived.
All of those data
will be available.
NICK PATON WALSH: But the
same problem emerges again.
It will be China and China
alone doing the testing
and reporting their results.
The US's recent report into
the origins of the coronavirus
and statements from allies
have all demanded greater
transparency from China.
But now, this key
data is being examined
a full two years later.
And there's no plan as it stands
for outsiders like the WHO
to be allowed in on it.
- In order to make it convincing
and credible, the results,
I mean, ideally,
you want to involve
the WHO or the foreign experts.
- I'm not completely
certain that China
has not done this testing and
has not shared the results.
- What we always say
is trust but verify.
It surely would be better if the
Chinese scientists would permit
external scientists to be
with them to collaborate
to do this all together.
NICK PATON WALSH: But
instead, this vital remaining
clue risks being mired in
recriminations and uncertainty
again.
Two years, Jake.
Still two years now since
the virus most likely,
according to a lot of the
studies, got into humans.
We're still asking
these questions.
It's not like China
isn't extremely curious,
doesn't spend millions every
year in trying to learn
more about viruses in general.
So you heard one of the
experts touch on it there.
There is some skepticism as
to whether these tests may not
possibly have already been done.
But great pressure for them
to happen possibly again,
or for the first time now
and for those results,
if not even the process
to be made public
and shared globally.
Jake.
JAKE TAPPER: Nick, where does
this leave the ongoing debate
about the origins of COVID?
NICK PATON WALSH:
Yeah, I mean, look.
This has been a huge issue
of geopolitical contention.
China's rivals pointing at it
essentially saying that maybe
a lab leak was involved.
The evidence behind
that not public.
And so this particular
set of samples
could, if they
revealed a cluster
around people near a
laboratory, point to that.
But more likely, it's all
about leading to where
the natural origins of
this could have been,
the Southern supply
chains of wet markets,
other places in China
which are known areas where
the viruses could have spread
into humans in the past,
and trying to dig into that.
That's what this is such a
vital set of live clues for.
Jake.
JAKE TAPPER: All right, Nick.
Thanks so much.
Appreciate it.